hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay I don't think I
hear the guy down there anymore so I'm
just gonna go here we go yeah I don't
know where he ran off to her why he just
popped in for a spell spot Tootsie as I
say in my best British puts it pretty
bad if any of you are a British I
apologize I just get out here I got the
two orbs service biscuit - can't
remember oh yeah two orbs at the lines
and the angels need to put them at the
angels before the Lions God take care of
the ladies before the the lines if you
know what I mean
ah go splats no splats I like no splat
hi and I swear like this this whole area
is like exceptionally in-depth with the
amount of stuff that's going on here
it's just kind of crazy that he's using
more with less space a lot of custom map
or custom stories that I've played and I
haven't played a lot I've only played
about you know six or seven I think a
lot of them will not take advantage of
the fact that you can have multiple
puzzles in the same area and just have
people go back and forth and then just
script different things for when things
happen like that oh this way you know I
mean I'm not saying that there's a right
way in a long way but you know just if
you take advantage of what you have then
the game is gonna last longer and if
it's good that's a good thing I mean you
can't just have your guys running in
circles pacing of course it's important
but in certain situations is very good
oh come on let's go get hmm okay since
black didn't splat me I'm unsplit able
come on come on
okay tears okay now treat the ladies
first ladies what the hell it's already
an orb here oh wait a minute yeah that's
right there was already orbs in front of
them oh that one has an orb okay I guess
I got the lady before the line anyway so
click
ah
ding-dong big bomb I got it I'm the best
apparently all right Thank You babies
thank you for being so kind to me hmm
I just venture off you stay here you
stay and be beautiful
you're too out there now I guess I'm
actually gonna go into the castle
which could be good could be bad
Oh ain't this Purdy I like it
it'd take a simple door would suffice
but oh well
Hey
I made it this is my father's old
servants Church my brothers should be
close by I think your brother betrayed
you
I think your brother your brother your
brother is into them some dark things I
can't even talk share
okay nice layout
oh hello babies how you doing hi there
and it's staring at you what I saw
creepy topic yeah look down to ground
alright the door has a small moon crest
next to the lock all righty then alright
small moon Chris no brother
what has father done to you Oh God
father you will pay for this
I'm sorry brother I was too late okay
maybe the weather is not into bad stuff
I swear I will revenge it brother
the first time to find our mother this
blue flame strange it feels cold I need
to be extremely cautious here
okie dokie maybe he's not dead maybe
it's all trick dear brother I don't
think I'm gonna make it the servants
that some of the prisoners have gone
missing and the think he knows I've been
reading his notes so he's been locking
himself in the lab for the past days
he's been acting strange around me
plus his appearances took a turn for the
worse but I don't dare to say a thing
about did to him because I would alert
him of my suspicions toward his work
brother you need to know that the evil
that father let out is growing stronger
he's coming after you so move fast we
will not stop until every one that's
against it dies I've seen signs of it in
the cellar growing quietly in the dark
it seems the darkness helps it grow
strong so if you have to go in the
cellar
watch yourself down there if you need to
go there just get in Todd's room you
will have a key to it if you are trying
to get to father you will have to go
through the hub to get to the lab rather
this may be the last time I get to write
you things have gotten really bad in
here around here and I fear the things
have been wandering in the halls at
night taking servants in their sleep
I can feel it coming for me this evil
essence I fear for my and my mother's
safety my and mother's safety we're
going to wait one more day for you to
come if you don't arrive by then we
leave this place first thing in the
morning brother I have to tell you
something very important you owe genin
oh [ __ ] here were okay
you know Tenzin it's covered in blood
okay Tara I need you for a second Jambu
cos key ah what not fair oh ah watch it
was those things oh I was ready okay
what what that sky door key what oh okay
alright then what am I supposed to do oh
man
ah do I have a note
no mementos available yes oh my lord
yes yeah you like that or you don't ask
too bad alright whatever
like like bling bling ling-ling
door has a small moon crest next to the
lock yeah what does it mean oh okay
needs a small moon crust hello baby can
you help me out here
I seem to be at a loss okay
alright fine I gotta figure it out on my
own as always say alright I suppose I
could do that ah there's something in
the water
aha I got it picked up unlocks moon door
ah thank you thank you for that okay ooh
I'm almost out of oil I don't like being
almost out of oil oh man here we go out
there we go this looks creepy that's a
pretty long hallway check this out first
ah tortured but nope haha this looks
like a good door I'll go in here first
why would the brother just be hanging
around with the father unless I guess
you know the father drag that brother
and mother his family with them he's
totes crazy man I still think there's
something more to it oh and someone said
that this is flaming only changes when
your sanity lowers that would explain a
lot I wouldn't
okay so the board look weak I will need
to find a crowbar or something to break
them I'm guessing a crowbar and not
something what happen to my handler my
hammer really shatter into pieces at
that chest must have been oh there we go
it's been a really tough chest whatever
up oh wait there was another door let's
see that lying to make the way out now
let's go down this hallway
cuz I'm feeling brave let's go down to
the cellar
not just yet because people warned me
about the cellar let me just check down
here and I need to I think I maybe go in
and say but I could see something moving
down here
well bring it on
okay night is it bring it on in just a
hot minute just a hot second
that could exactly ah that's not a check
my drawers nope
grooming anything in there nope okay
there's nothing here
ah I know it I do it I do it oh give it
good you didn't see a thing you didn't
see anything back out haha
you lie the door lied to you
why did that monster come after I find
the goodies Scottie
ah Vicki haha yeah get out of here go
away no one likes you
you're fat and you're ugly that's right
don't think I forgot how fat you sound
we're not gonna come in the room cuz
you're scared little baby that's what I
thought
that's what I think he thought with my
thought brain that you're ugly oh there
you are
okay you've never got me in the closet
before I don't know why that should
start now get out of here
get out of here Oh get out of here come
on
practically opening a closet now
are you worthy I don't see them ah wait
there is that's okay
Oh toughen up Daniel or whoever this is
I forget who I forget the names of my
main characters applause I don't even
know this guy got a main character named
Oh toughen it up take some sanity potion
oh that was him why is he just wandering
about what do I do
do I make a run for it screw this I'm
running rude you didn't see anything
oh you didn't see anything oh what's
that nope ha ha wait what do I do now
hmm I may not have thought this through
all the way considering that I can't go
anywhere now he didn't seem to go away
though son just guessing if you bash it
down wonder where I can just slip out
the other one or yeah Paul Bobo I even
see you okay I think we're good ah there
we go the old clear music I don't know
what the deal with that was just gotta
throw a monster I mean just when I'm
trying to get some goodies let's see
what's down here up Matt memento
the lock is too good I will need a key
to get in the bedroom okay
there's a lot of doors
whoa ah well I've just blown in the wind
that doesn't scare me
dead guy done careful smash just scare
me I get that note the second
cissie's notes are very lengthy and take
some time to read they're gonna prepare
us I know clay is kissing the Masters
ass he's been talking about getting his
room bigger or a small add on clay said
the master was going to let him work
with him on his experiments that lucky
bastard and for some reason it seems
like he always has more coins on in
Mitte as well I think I'm gonna steal
the key from the head servant and sneak
into his room and see what he's is
secret I tried to steal the key but the
doors locked all the time and at night I
hear noises coming out from there it
just doesn't seem normal at all plus he
has been sick for a month now so I
better stay out of that place ever since
I tried to break into that room I been
hearing someone's scratching and
whispering at my door I can't sleep like
this but I'm not going to look I know
things have been getting ugly around
here and now they want to take me to oh
yes they're watching you right now
Oh
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ]
honey God hello is someone there yes
someone's here
Oh monster Finn I think you might want
to move this conversation along Oh your
brother's already dead
oh yes I've seen him in the church looks
like it father hit him over the head
with a hammer but there was some kind of
blue flame thrown them as well do you
know what that is do you have any news
from my mother who Sarah that oh there's
a kind of a monster okay
and I'm actually running out over time a
god oh man I
I don't know if your mother is alright
what I know is the blue flame in the
ritual to bring back the dead so your
brother will definitely become one of
those things take their civil get you
into clay drum it may have there
something you can use but he was close
to your father
I'll stay here for now but I promise
I'll see you again later now please
leave it Sara someone oh so fine ah
Oh God it's your brother because he is
just standing there you walk slowly and
quietly maybe you can Steven it all
right that's gonna have to wait God how
could you tell that he was just dead
you're gonna God okay all right I'm all
out of time for this episode so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always as always I'll see you in the
next part
bye bye